OVER.
JOHNSSON HAS NOWHERE TO GO
AFTER THAT ONE, SO MURPHY 7.
TURNOVER.
HAGEL, HE SCORES!
BRANDON HAGEL, OFF THE NEW
JERSEY THROW AWAY,VES, HE SHOOTE
SCORES!
JACK HUGHES, AND THE HAWKS
TURNED IT OVER, ANSWERING THE
DEVILS' TURNOVER.
IT IS A  TURNOVERS,  IT UP.
PASS, IN FRONT COULD
THEY SCORE.
IT'S FIRED HOME BY
SHARANGOVICH.  RINK WIDE.
THERE COMES KANE.
HE SHOOTS.
HE SCORES!
PATRICK KANE, SHOR
ALEX DeBRINCAT. KANE JUST
DROPPED THAT A LITTLE BIT
LOWER,STROME.
OH, A SECOND SAVE BY GILLIES,
PATRICK KANE, EITHER HAGEL OR
STROME, A NEAT  REDIREAKEN BY K
HE WILL HAVE A CHANCE AT A
POWER PLAYAYMOVING RIGHT TO
LEFT, AND HAGEL PICKS HIS SPOT
>> PICE.
HE HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE FOR THE
KNOW WHAT THE PK DOES, WHAT THE
POWER PLAY DOES.
IT'S AN SIEGENTHALER TRIED.
HE SCORES.
POSITIONING THEIR.
HE DID NOT SEE THAT ONE GO IN
PASSED HIM ABOVE THE LEFT
SHOULDER, SO THE DEVILS  CALEY S
ONLY ONE TEAM IN THE LEAGUE
THAT HAS A
PHILIPP KURASHEV AND KIRBY, AND
THE HAWKS HAVE A TWO-GOAL LEAD.
>> Caley: LET THE FLOODGATES
OPEN.
ON
1. HE SCORES.
NICE PASSING PLAY, FINDING
JESPER BRATT.
HE POUNDED A 1 TIMER
NOBODY ON JESPER BRATT.
NICE JOB, FINISHING  88 READ,
AND HIS FOURTH P Caley:  HAT TR
ICE.
HE W KNOCKED AWAY.
LOOKING FOR AN EMPTY NETTER.
HE'S GOING TO ADD TO
UNIT